[Music]
journalism was in my family a little bit
my dad is a correspondent for CBS so it
was in the air I started at MSNBC as a
producer and then sort of weaseled my
way onto the air I went from there to
Morning Joe and then I run across the
street at about eight o'clock every
morning blue the Today Show I'm willie
Geist and these are my ten essentials I
love this Baxter of California shave
balm I want to be real honest with you
if they'd let me
eat this I would eat this stuff it's
really good it's not oily and it's not
overwhelming I heard you like mr. GU
smooth now when I'm not at work or
especially on the weekend this is kind
of what it looks like this is a ratty
old Derek Jeter t-shirt which doesn't
just have a hole in the back of it it's
got air conditioned it's just I picked
up in London at the Summer Olympics it's
an official T USA gear pair of jeans
here old reliables basically flew on the
same lines every weekend love these um
full Han shoes they're called lunar
grams they look like a buck but they
feel like a sneaker when you walk in
it's good weekend shoe this is Skippy
extra crunchy super chunk peanut butter
just go right down
[Music]
not what you've done there it's a
healthy meal you've lost it bread so
you're not getting the carbs in the
sandwich and by the way don't go for the
low fat stuff you can taste the
difference it's not worthless we're all
gonna die eventually anyway I love a
chocolate-chip cookie and I love no
chocolate chip cookie more than Helens
kitchen of Charlotte North Carolina I
don't know if you can see in the front
just a couple grains there of sea salt
that makes all the difference in the
world
I love these sunglasses they're called
War V Parker I'm a sucker for these
American stories it was four buddies who
decided that sunglasses cost too much
that that was ridiculous
so they got together in making
sunglasses that cost under $100 and I
don't look bad either
Warby Parker I wear a dress shirt every
single day to work on television like
the one I'm wearing now the company is
called lead berry and they make shirts
that actually fit you they don't they're
not tailored shirt but they feel like
they are this is the part where I
pretend I take the subway living in New
York City you cannot live without this
this is the MetroCard for the subway
it's the best it's the fastest it's the
quickest it's the most interesting way
to get anywhere in New York City one of
the highlights of every day for me is
the dance party we have in our apartment
at about 6 o'clock we just crank up the
Bose speakers get out the iTunes and
throw down with a five and
three-year-old
I have two kids who run around furiously
a lot of times they fall down hit their
face and decided to dining room table
but they get right back up because they
hear the smooth smooth sounds with LMFAO
and then through our speakers this one's
pretty self-explanatory
Visine the problem is you kind of get
addicted to it so it looks like I'm
advising the customer for life when you
have a five year old and a three year
old this becomes big no central in your
life good Kentucky Bourbon
this is maker's mark I have and you go a
lot of directions any variety of
Kentucky Bourbon some good stuff
it helps life go down a little bit
smoother
thanks for feigning interest your big
takeaway I'm a guy who eats Skippy
peanut butter out of the jar and chases
it down with straight whiskey my drink
is a good bourbon on the rocks with a
little splash of ginger ale up top
what's your drink of choice you can
leave comments below here or tweet us at
hashtag GQ ten
[Music]